bonsoir tristan cabello merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
l'information du jour donne un tome qui
finalement donne son feu vert pour la
transition avec joe biden l'échec de ces
recours en justice et la validation du
résultat en pennsylvanie et dans l'état
du michigan l'ont obligé à céder
c'est l'analyse qu'on peut en tirer
aujourd'hui oui tout à fait et donc il y
avait à peu près 25 eu recours en
justice de la part de trump je crois
qu'il n'y en a qu'un seul qui a été
jusqu'au bout il y en a 24 qui ont été
rejetées donc là on peut vraiment dire
que l'administration trump n'avait pas
du tout de preuves à fournir un au juge
et particulièrement leur au gouverneur
même des républicains donc non pas
accepter ces recours en justice
il n'y a vraiment plus aucun recours
pour trump dans cette élection
maintenant donc la transition est
effectué un lit murphy a signé la lettre
ait donc la transition est en marche
alors néanmoins donaldson ne veut pas
reconnaître sa sa défaite vous arrivez à
expliquer cette stratégie du président
sortant oui tout à fait alors donateurs
ne veut pas accepter sa défaite ne veut
pas dire sa défaite il sombrait la
rumeur qui court ici à washington c'est
qu'il est déjà sur le coup d'après donc
ils tenteraient de ne pas venir à
l'inauguration et il est déjà en train
de former une chaîne de télévision qui
va s'appeler 30 network et qui sera
certainement annoncer dans les tout
prochains mois donc d'être prêt quand
ceux déjà sa reconversion et je crois
que c'est vraiment un coup marketing un
coup de relations publiques très
important pour lui de ne pas concéder
cette élection sa reconversion ça veut
dire un retour sur le devant de la scène
politique dans quatre ans alors il est
tout à fait possible que donald trump
reviennent dans quatre ans puisque sa
base est très très forte
la parti républicain est très ancrée
temps de 36 mhz
c'est quelqu'un qui quand même ne
l'oublions pas a eu
le plus c'est le candidat sortant
républicain qui a eu le plus de voix
dans une élection
donc c'est quelqu'un de très très fort
dans le parti républicain et il ya tant
à penser qu'avec sa chaîne donc 30
network il puisse là aussi agrandir sa
base et critiqué le mandat de bail donne
comme il commence déjà à le faire
aujourd'hui
alors joe boyd anin de son côté a
commencé à présenter son gouvernement
comme ans sont accueillis les premiers
noms par les américains alors ils sont
assez bien accueilli
ce sont des gens qui nous sont présentés
comme compétents pragmatique centriste
puis j'ai envie de dire en fait joe
biden eh bien il met en marche son
programme et son programme c'était quoi
c'était virbac beurre alors là on est
dans la période un peu beard bac c'est à
dire qu'il reconstruit et le
reconstruire vraiment à l'identique des
années obama dont ce sont vraiment des
nominations qui aurait pu être fait suur
obama ou sous le mandat direct hillary
clinton si elle avait été élue ce sont
vraiment des anciens démocrate des gens
qu'on voit depuis 30 ans dans les allées
du pouvoir à washington
je pense qu'il ya vraiment deux
problèmes là pour les américains c'est
que 1 on vend ces gens comme étant des
pragmatiques
or c'est quand même sont quand même des
idéologues un des idéologues de de
l'interventionnisme américain du
néolibéralisme et puis surtout on nous
dit qu'ils sont très compétents or les
américains ne s'y trompe pas ce sont des
gens qui pendant 30 ans 40 ans ont été
constamment jamais envie de dire avec
acharnement du mauvais côté de
l'histoire
pour la guerre en irak pour la guerre en
afghanistan pour le bombardement de la
libye etc etc
donc il ya quand même
des oppositions des paradoxes ici dont
les américains sont très au courant
une phrase qui a attiré mon attention en
tout cas tout à l'heure joe biden qui se
dit prêt je suis ta à guider le monde
les a menés afin pas de jaux bagdad mais
les états unis sont presque prêts à
guider le monde
comment doit-on interpréter cette
remarque pour le moins un petit peu
étonnante on parle d'ingérence partout
voilà les pays sont souvent accusés
d'ingérence à on en sait quelque chose
on travaille pour une chaîne russe la
france hier emmanuel macron en algérie
voilà les américains prêts à guider le
monde ça veut dire quoi ça c'est pas
très surprenant en fait parce que quand
même
anthony donc blinken et toute
administration qui a été en fait nommer
jusqu'ici ce sont d interventionnisme ce
sont des interventionnistes des gens qui
ont été tout le temps pendant 30 ans
pour l'interventionnisme américain
alors là je crois que puisque des drains
fois qu'ils ont été au pouvoir c'était
quand même sous les années obama donc un
monde qui était vraiment très différent
je crois qu'ils n'ont pas encore agencé
ou opter t1 comme on dit ici aux
etats-unis leur logiciel politique et je
crois qu'il va voir quand même des
regrets qui vont être très brutaux pour
eux puisque voilà les états unis ne sont
plus le grand pouvoir qu'ils étaient ne
serait ce qu il ya 4 ou 8 ans justement
comment ça va c'était ma prochaine
question comment ça va se passer dans ce
contexte notamment les rapports avec des
pays comme la chine
quand on voit effectivement ce type de
sortie la part de joe biden tout à fait
alors le focus de anthony blinken c'est
la chine et il a dit encore hier c'est à
dire qu'ils croient et là encore c'est
quand même un logiciel qui est quand
même tout à fait dépasser il croit
vraiment que les états unis en tant que
grande démocratie doivent montrer le
chemin
c'est quelque chose que il faut quand
même il donnait ce crédit donald trump
avait quand même arrêter de faire donc
anti anthony blinken sous la direction
de joe biden va revenir
ira dans le concert des relations
internationales pour tenter de voilà
d'être le leader du monde libre
alors il nous faudra encore quelques
mois pour savoir comment ces choses vont
se dérouler mais je crois que vraiment
encore une fois ici on voit que c est
une administration qui est marqué par
les le début des années 2000 c'est à
dire le délai des années obama avec qui
n'a pas encore fait sa révolution
idéologique justement joe biden qui se
dit vers l'apaisement
vous le dites vous-même jo donald trump
lui en tout cas n'était peut-être pas
très apaisant dans ces personnalités
mais aller vers les dirigeants du monde
tenter d'apaiser les choses s'étaient
parfois critiquée notamment quand il a
rencontré le dirigeant nord-coréen
qu'est ce qui va se passer avec joe
bananas qui a horreur justement une
levée de ces tensions avec les autres
pays alors il ya tout
on peut penser vraiment qu'il y aura une
présidence assez calme assez normal et
donc une stabilisation des tensions
internationales
vous savez tous les stratégistes
démocrates nous dise ce qu'on veut pour
cette pour cette présidence est une
présidence normale
on veut que les gens ne ne se ne dépasse
pas de politique aux dîners familiaux
on veut que les gens redeviennent
reviennent à leur vie normale ne
commande pas les tweets chaque chaque
jour est donc le but vraiment de bail
donne c'est en ce moment d'apaiser de
solidifier son administration mais
encore plus importante apparaître comme
quelqu'un de tout à fait technocratique
et de tout à fait normal en opposition
entre hommes alors les prochaines
semaines nous diront si ça marche aux
yeux des américains
il est possible que ça puisse marcher
mais s'il est vrai quand même que 30
sera toujours là et que 30 se se
mobilisera pour pour
pour occuper l'espace médiatique merci
en tout cas à vous tristan cabello
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir